リーダーシップのあり方について私の考え方をシェアさせていただきます
私があの大学を卒業して初めて組織という会社という組織に入ったのが
バブルも終わりかけながらまで世の中がこうキラキラとしていた
そんな時代だったんですね私もキラキラしてっ
いきいきだったんですが大学の時にラジオの dj というのをさせて頂いた経験も
あって地元神戸の広告代理店に就職します
えっと当時12名入社して3名が女性でした
あの日本政府が男女雇用機会均等法という男女平等に雇用しましょうねっていう法律を
執行してから4年ぐらいでして
また会社自体が男女をどうやって平等に雇用したらいいのっていうを模索しているよう
な時代だったと思います
で私が営業部に配属されまして
当時の模様ですがデジタル自体じゃないのでも書類の山に囲まれていますこれ広告代理
店の模様だったんですけれども
いろんなスタイルの営業を経験するんですが
案件が大きくなれば大きくなるほど女性としての壁をすごく感じてたんですね
なかなか信用していただけないまあですジョンメーカー皆さん男性ですし
まぁこんな小娘が入ってもなかなか信用していただけなかったんですけれどもそこで私
はあるクライアントの仕事がしたいと思ってそのプラントのリサーチを始めました
どんなターゲットで
どんなそのターゲットがどんなライフスタイルを送っててどんなメディアに接してて
どんなコピーだったら心に響くのか
そして新しいアイディアこんな広告の使い方どうですかっていうものもどんどん
プレゼンの方に盛り込んで言ったらそういった男性たちもいつかこう
耳を傾けてくれるようになったんですね
で
諸先輩方がどんなに入っても撮れなかった歩くラインとゲットすることができたんです
すごく嬉しかったです
よく頑張ったで賞っていう素晴らしい賞を頂くんですけれども
その時にその上司に言われたのがおはょそれ
この仕事とったな12年12名いる新入社員のうちお前が一番初めに止めると思ったの
に
というあのお褒めの言葉をいただけました
で仕事も楽しくなってか頑張ろうかなと思っているときに
同期の男性と結婚をすることになるんです
当時7
日本女性といたしましてはえ
どこか疑っているところもありながら仕事=結婚=仕事を辞めるというふうに思ってい
ましたしそれが美徳だと思ってたとねあの上司にすいません結婚するんで会社辞めます
うおめでとうって言われるんかなと思った
当時の上司になんでやねんと
続けたらええねんっていう風に言われたんですね
すっごいショックだったんです
あ
そんな風に考えてもいいやっていうふうに思いました
素直にそう思ったんです
さっきのなんとか moment じゃないですけど
で
ああの壁をつくってたのは自分自身だなぁと
その常識っていう壁からこうてられなかったのを自分自身だったんだなというふうに
その時思いました
ってここで今の私を形成しているかもしれないひとつのあの幼い時の出来事の話をさせ
ていただきます
私の両親は私が10歳のときに離婚したんですけれども
あの前の小学校の友達に売買いうこともできずにあるゴールデンウィークのある日に
母親と2人で家を飛びを飛び出すことになるんですね
で新しい学校に入って友達あっすぐ出来るんですがその友達たからお父さん何してるの
惹かれた時に当時まだその離婚っていうのがそんなにポピュラーじゃなかった時代です
し
あの+はとずれにあったということもあるので
なんて説明していいかわかんなかったんですねお父さん
死んだという風に言ってたんですけども
なんか自分が不幸の中の少女やというふうに思い込むようになってきたんですね
そんなときにある日少女に出会います
たまたまどうかで目が合ってニコってしてくれた少女と友達になるんですね
その少女がも私毎日幸せやって言うんですっでにこにこにこにこしてて私と
誕生にこうしゃべることだけでも楽しい言ってくれる
てい
ロスそんなすっ
少女見ているだけで周りが幸せになるようなあの素晴らしい症状でした
ん
でそのしばらくして周りの友達から聞くことになるんですけれども実はその少女はご
両親がいらっしゃらなくて
施設から通ってる女の子だったんですね
私はもう
母親からあふれんばかりの愛情今でも too much 内蔵と時々思うんです
けれども
いただいてるのに勉強も運動も頑張って友達もいっぱいいるのに何にが不幸せなんだと
同じ状況でもちょっと見る角度を変えるとものすごく幸せになれるなっていうふうに
思いました
当時小学校5年生の私が書いたポエムがあるんですけれども
毎日の普通の幸せが一番幸せ後毎日普通に生きようと思っても何か考案エクスペクト
いうなことが起こって
なかなか
通常の普通な生活ができないそれが一番難しいことかもしれないしそれが一番幸せな
ことかなというふうに当時
可能
子供ながらに考えました
まあそんな私をですね姫
頭の代理店に行った時に地元の頭のクランかさんばっかりだったのでもっとナショナル
クライアント
テレビに出てくるようなナショナルクライアント担当したいと思うようになって
いろいろ就職活動して大阪の広告代理店に入ります
楽しかったんですが
いやいやいや本当はグローバルのクライアント担当したいと思うようになって英語の
勉強も始めまして今の会社に入ることになります
やっぱり夢は
まず思うそして実行するとかなっていくもんだなというふうに思います
しかし今の会社に入っていきなりも英語の壁にぶつかるんですね
映画なんかしゃべらんでよってられたのに院長の九州王者分 english から
始まって毎日毎日も大変だったんですけれども
ここでも
思ってたグローバルのクライアントの担当もできたし
方の勉強もしながらお給料もらえると
なんてラッキーなんだと思いながら働いていました
でそうするうちにしばらくしてそのあるクライアントのアジア全体のリーダーになり
なさいって言う
話をアメリカ人のボスからいただくんですね
そのポジションってその当時の会社の売り上げのほとんどでしたし
相手方の勾配の方との英語のネゴシエーションみたいなこともございましたし
会社の中でも日本人だけじゃなくて中国シンガポールマレーシアや
上年上の人と資産の人みんな
いるのをまとめないといけないっていう奪って当時の私にとってはタフなポジション
だったんですね
こういう時皆さんはどうされますでしょうかね
女性男性はねはいはいってために行くはる人多いと思うんです
過大評価する人多いんでね女性は過小評価する人が多いんで
私はここができないからちょっと無理ですって言っちゃう人もいるかもしれないです
けれどもそれってすごいもったいないですよね
目の前に来たそのチャレンジ opportunity っていうのは実は自分自身で
作り上げたチャンスでもあると思うので是非失敗を恐れずにチャレンジしてください
そうしてあのまあリーダーアジアのリーダーになった私も
どういうリーダーのスタイルを取って言ったらいいのかというのはすごいなぁみますか
あの日本の女性として
世界の皆様に舐められたな緩急気持ちはあったと思うんですね
あの強いリーダーシップというのを示さないといけないと思って男性ぽく振る舞わない
といけないのかなとかあの
命令形で結果だけを求めて命令形で色々お話しないといけないのかしら声を低くして
喋られた
いけないかしらといろいろ考えたんですけれども結局そのチームをまとめてん
何かとで試乗して言って実行していくそして成果を出していく
まあそういう単純なことなんで頑張ろうと思いながら
考えましたそのチームをチームの成果を上げていくというところで組織において大きく
二つのタイプのお仕事があるのかなと思うんですね
でひょっとしてやっぱり男性の方が得意かもしれないハンティングのような仕事
数字を取りに行く営業してあの this ああん
レベにをとっていくっていうのお仕事バーサ数
その仕事もらって効率よく回していくとか
あのサービスの質を上げていくどちらかというと女性の方が得意かもしれないそういう
お仕事があると思います
どちらが大切だ召喚
もちろんその時々によっては瞬時には
a
通常あげなきゃとかあの質を上げなかっ
サービスの質を上げないとということあると思うんですが
企業が長く生きていくにことに関してはその両方のバランスというのが大事だと思うん
ですね
でその実は問題なのはバランス良く評価できているか
っていうことだと思うんです
とかく今の評価制度を作り上げた世代の方々が男性の方が多いからかもしれません
けれども
やはりこうハンティングのお仕事の方が評価されることが多いんじゃないかなと思い
ます
今後この両方バランスよく
評価できるリーダーボスが増えていけばこの世の中はもっともっと良くなるんじゃない
かなと思ってます
結果あのやっぱ男女関係ないっていうことに
アド引き続きます
一番初めの会社で女性は男性の2倍努力しないと同じ土俵に立てないと思ったことをお
話ししましたけれどもいまとなっては人より2倍努力したり工夫したり
頑張った人がやはり一歩前に出るんじゃないかなと
さのように思います
女性でもハンティング私のようにはどちらかと言うとハンティングが得意な人もいれば
男性でも効率よくマンして行くほうが得意っていう方もいらっしゃるので
その個性個性を見極めるとその個性個性を見極めながら
リーダーもリーダー自身の個人の個性を使いながらチームのパ
フォーマンスが2人が3人3人が5人の力を出せるようなことになれば
日ば美しいんじゃないかなと思います
そしてそのリーダーシップのあり方についてスタイリーについてですが
結局自分自身であるしかないんですよね
教科書に書いてあるようなリーダーシップ書に書いてあるようなものを真似することも
もちろんできますがその方が
有楽かもしれない失敗した時にエクスキューズできるから
でも
自分自身なるって実は凄い勇気のいることだと思うんです素を見せる自分のベストを
見せる
まず自分のいいとか何かっていうのに気づいてそれを
ん
強みとして武器として使っていく
そしてその使っていくことの勇気を持つ
っていうことがすごい大事じゃないかなと思います
今私はの会社でですね例えば水陶器のポットがなくなってたら進んでおお水入れに行き
ますし
チームの皆に持つ住んで冗談いなった今日のシャツ片やなぁいいながらか女に声かけて
いくますし
一緒に営業に出かけるの好きですしこう何かオポチュニティがないかなと思って出かけ
て行くのも大好きです
そんなを私と一緒に私のチームが今日も頑張ろうと思ってくれると私は最高に幸せです
ていけベルマツ